[music]
antiziganism is probably one of the
strongest forms of racism we have in
europe cupid 19 has shown in
eastern europe that antiziganism is
still very strongly represented in the majority society
[music]
important is the priority is the fight
against antiziganism at all levels of
the strategies  we are no longer talking
about integration but about
inclusion and participation then it is important to involve
people on all levels on an equal footing
the european payment and billing
kitchen fair living conditions and health
care station i was
discriminated against at school i didn’t have the
same opportunities
myself  Today, as a member of parliament,
I very often still experience antiziganism and
discrimination because of my ethnic
affiliations
[music]